the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another a Song of Ice and Fire
video today I want to talk about Lady
Stoneheart
who is also known as Catelyn Stark I
decided to make this video because in
all honesty I haven't seen too many
people talk about what I want to discuss
today now I'm sure you have seen videos
on her before but that's mostly because
fans have been wondering if she would
ever make an appearance in the show I
think it's way too late to introduce
Lady Stoneheart in Game of Thrones so
this video is only in reference to the
books I know some of you haven't read
them yet but that's okay because I will
add some context before I get to the
main question on the video I do
apologize if you already read the books
and know all the details but I have to
make sure everyone watching this is
brought up to speed in order to do this
I figured I should start off by giving a
quick recap of the red wedding because
Lady Stoneheart story begins just three
days after that tragic event for those
of you that don't know I did make a
video a few months ago where I read the
entire red wedding chapter which did
happen through Kaitlyn's point of view I
kinda wish I would have made this video
right after that one when all the
details were still fresh on everyone's
mind but even if you've only seen the
show it was such an iconic moment those
images will be very hard to forget I'll
also play some of the clips as I'm
discussing this so let's start right
there when Catelyn Stark is killed at
the red wedding as we all know the red
wedding was a massacre that took place
at the twins during in Meerut Ollie and
Roslin Frey's wedding feast the main
person who orchestrated this event was
Tywin Lannister as far as we know he
never actually met with Roose Bolton and
Walder Frey in person but through
several letters he conspired to bring an
end to the northern rebellion what
should have been a fun night of
celebration ended up becoming a
slaughter the king in the north
Robb Stark his mother Catelyn Stark
along with thousands of his soldiers
were butchered as the rains of castamere
stood in as the soundtrack during one of
the most devastating moments in northern
history the chapter ends with Catelyn
Stark's death
now what we don't see in Game of Thrones
is what happens next we did see what
they did to Robb Stark they cut off his
head and they replaced it with gray
winds then in a mocking like fashion
they paraded his desecrated body through
the cheering crowd that was just outside
of the main dining hall after Catelyn
Stark's throat was slit her body was
then dumped into the river where it
would stay for the next couple days now
what's very interesting is and some of
you may not know this but Arya Stark is
actually the one who finds her mother's
body floating in the river at the time
the Catlins body is found Arya is inside
of her direwolf Nymeria as she is with
her pack
they never reveal any of this in the
show but Arya does have this ability in
the books and it led to her finding her
mother now keep in mind this is just a
few days after the red wedding so Arya
is still traveling with the Hound this
is when the Hound decides he can take
Arya to her aunt in the Vale and
hopefully ransom her off there so as
they're traveling they stop for the
night to get some rest and this is what
happens when arya lays down to go to
sleep that night she went to sleep
thinking of her mother and wondering if
she should kill the Hound in his sleep
and rescue lady Catelyn herself when she
closed her eyes she saw her mother's
face against the back of her eyelids
she's so close I could almost smell her
and then she could smell her the scent
was faint beneath the other smells
beneath the moss and mud and water in
the stench of rotting Reed's and rotting
men she padded slowly through the soft
ground to the river's edge lapped up a
drink then lifted her head to sniff the
sky was grey and thick with cloud the
river green and full of floating things
dead men clogged the shallows some still
moving as the water pushed them others
washed up on the banks the crows were
there to screaming at the wolves and
filling the air with feathers their
blood was hotter and one of her sisters
had snapped that one as it took flight
and caught it by the wing it made her
want to crow herself she wanted to taste
the blood to hear the bones crunching
beneath her teeth to fill her belly with
warm flesh instead of cold she was
hungry in the meat was all around but
she knew she could not eat the scent was
stronger now she pricked her ears up and
listened to the grumbles of her pack the
shriek of anger crows the whirr of wings
and sound of running water somewhere far
off she could hear the horses and the
calls a living man
but they were not what mattered only the
scent mattered she sniffed the air again
there it was and now she saw it too
something pale and white drifting down
the river
turning where it brushed against the
snag the reeds bowed down before it she
splashed noisily through the shallows
and threw herself into the deeper water
her legs turning the current was strong
but she was stronger she swam following
her nose the river smells were rich and
wet but those were not the smells that
pulled her she paddled after the
shortbread whisper of cold blood the
sweet stench of death she chased them as
she had often chased a red deer through
the trees and in the end she ran them
down and her jaw closed around a pale
white arm she shook it to make it move
but there was only death and blood in
her mouth by now she was tiring and it
was all she could do to pull the body
back to the shore as she dragged it up
the muddy Bank one of her little
brothers came prowling his tongue
hanging from his mouth she had to snarl
to drive him off or else he would have
fed only then did she stop to shake the
water from her fur the white thing lay
facedown in the mud her dead flesh
wrinkled and pale cold blood trickling
from her throat rise
she thought rise and eat and run with us
the sound of horses turned her head men
they were coming from downwind so she
had not smelled them but now they were
almost here men on horses with flapping
black and yellow and pink wings and long
shiny claws in hand some of our younger
brothers bared their teeth to defend the
body they found but she snapped at them
until they scattered that was the way of
the wild deer and hares and crows fled
before wolves and wolves fled from men
she abandoned the cold white prize in
the mud where she had dragged it and ran
and felton and shame so as you can see
Arya drags her mother's body out of the
river but she has to abandon the body
because men and horses are beginning to
arrive at the scene the men that are
coming through the woods are their
Brotherhood without banners
Thor's of Mayor beric Dondarrion and
several others as they get closer to the
riverbank they come upon a horrific
sight when they noticed Catelyn Stark's
dead body if he saw my red wedding
chapter reading video then you know
right before Catelyn was killed she
basically went mad after she witnessed
her son's death
she dug her fingernails deep into her
own face and began to scratch off strips
of flesh then she started laughing like
a maniac that eventually turned into
screams some of the people in attendance
even said she had gone mad and lost her
wits so as you can imagine
Catlins body and face was in rough shape
her face was torn to pieces her neck had
a gaping hole from ear to ear then her
body set in the water for several days
we get a good description of Lady
Stoneheart Sapir ins and this is what it
says her cloak in collar had the gash
the blade had made but her face was even
worse than he remembered the flesh had
gone putting soft in the water and
turned to the color of curdled milk half
her hair was gone and the rest had
turned as white in brittle as a Chrome's
beneath her scalp her face was shredded
skin in black blood where she had raped
herself with her nails but her eyes were
the most terrible thing her I saw him
and they hated she don't speak said the
big man in the yellow cloak you bloody
bastards cut her throat too deep for
that but she remembers now just to
clarify one thing Lady Stoneheart is
able to speak a little bit but she has
to cover her throat with her hand but
that doesn't even help that much because
her voice is very raspy and the words
are somewhat hard to hear it's not until
later that we find out how Catlin wants
Brock back from the dead some of you may
or may not remember a video I made a few
months ago about some of the most
disturbing scenes from the books that
the show left out well one of those
scenes I read was when Brienne of Tarth
got into a fight with the character
known as biter he was one of the men
that was locked up in the cage with Jack
and agar
while later in the books bran gets into
a crazy fight with this man that leaves
her nearly dead in fact she probably
would have been killed if it wasn't for
ginjury shoving a sword through the back
of his neck at the end of the fight
biter was on top of Brienne just beating
the [ __ ] out of her but thankfully again
jury came up from behind and killed him
Brienne ends up losing consciousness
from this fight and once she finally
wakes up she realizes she is being held
captive by the Brotherhood without
banners under suspicion of working with
the Lannisters
keep in mind Brienne still has the
Lannister sword Oathkeeper you see
brains close relationship with Jaime
Lannister is about to come back and bite
her right in the ass because Lady
Stoneheart is now on a mission to kill
any
one involved with the red wedding you
have to remember one of the last things
Catelyn heard before she was killed was
Jaime Lannister sends his regards so
even though lady Catelyn and Brienne
once had a good relationship you can see
how her close ties to Jaime can now
cause a bit of a problem
after Brienne wakes up and realizes she
is being held captive she finds out lady
Catelyn has rose from the dead and this
is what it said lady Catelyn tears
filled her eyes they said they said that
you were dead
she is said Thoris of mere the phrase
slashed her throat from ear to ear when
we found her by the river she was three
days dead Harwin begged me to give her
the kiss of life but it had been too
long I would not do it so Lord beric
Dondarrion put his lips to hers instead
and the flame of life passed from him to
her and she rose may the Lord of Light
protect us she rose as you can see
Brienne is in a bit of a predicament now
we know that Brienne is still trying to
help lady Catelyn by finding her
daughters but lady Catelyn isn't quite
sure who is still on her side so now
she's on a mission of vengeance just as
a side note Lady Stoneheart has a few
other nicknames that you might not know
about
she's also called the silent sister
mother merciless and my personal
favorite the hang woman now when Brienne
is brought before Lady Stoneheart she
has to try and explain her way out of
this situation but it falls on deaf ears
she does look kind of guilty not only
does she have the Lannister sword but
she also has a sign letter from King
Tommen what Jaime did give her to help
her stay safe while she looks for
Caitlyn's daughters but none of them
actually know that Jaime is actually
trying to honor his oath of promising to
make sure the stark sisters are safe
they assume Brienne plans on finding
them and handing them over to Cersei you
really can't blame her for thinking this
way because who can really trust Jaime
Lannister at that point especially after
the red wedding when one of the last
things you hear is Jaime Lannister sends
his regards
if I were Catelyn I would be thinking
the same thing Brienne also has Podrick
Payne with her and this doesn't help
either because everyone knows Podrick
was a Lannister Squire and not to
mention it was Podrick uncle who took
Ned's head off
however Brienne is given the opportunity
to get out of the situation but
she only has to do one thing all Lady
Stoneheart once from Brienne is Jaime
Lannister Brienne responds to this by
saying you don't understand Jaime
he saved me from being rate when the
bloody mummers took us anni later came
back for me
he lept into the bear pit empty-handed I
swear to you he is not the man he was
he sent me after sanso to keep her safe
he could not have had a part in the red
wedding lady Caitlyn's fingers dug deep
into her throat and the words came
rattling out choked and broken a stream
as cold as ice the Northman said she
says that you must choose take the sword
and slay the Kingslayer or be hanged for
a betrayer the sword or the noose
she says choose she says choose now can
you imagine how Brienne must have felt
in this moment I mean holy [ __ ] she has
two choices you either die right now
or find Jaime who we all know she loves
and kill him this choice isn't as easy
as it seems and this is one of the
reasons why I love that George are
Martin likes to write about the human
heart being in conflict with itself so
now brie and has this big choice to make
she only needs to say one word sword or
noose but Bryan says I cannot make that
choice there was a long silence after
that then Lady Stoneheart spoke again
this time Brienne understood her words
there were only two Lady Stoneheart said
hang them all three of them Brienne
Podrick in sirheo each of them had a
noose around their neck
Brienne felt the hemp constricting
digging into her skin jerking her chin
upward sir Hale was cursing them
eloquently but not the boy
Podrick never lifted his eyes not even
when his feet were jerked up off the
ground if this is another dream it is
time for me to awaken if this is real it
is time for me to die
all she could see was Podrick the noose
around his thin neck his legs twitching
her mouth opened pod was kicking choking
dying Bryan sucked the air in
desperately even as the rope was
strangling her nothing had ever hurt so
much she screamed a word
you see when Brienne sees Podrick dying
she decides to scream the
sword in order to be cut down but by
doing this she is also agreeing to find
Jaime Lannister and either kill him
herself
or bring him the Lady Stoneheart Bryan
does eventually make it to Jaime's camp
she tells Jaime she needs his help
saving Sansa from the Hound but she also
tells Jaime that he's got to come with
her alone or else she will be killed
unfortunately no new book has come out
yet so everyone is still waiting to find
out how this all plays out now this is
where I want to get into some of my own
thoughts and opinions on Lady Stoneheart
story I'm sorry if it took too long to
get to this point but I wanted to make
sure everyone gets a good sense of Lady
Stoneheart scre --nt status in the books
because the television show never goes
into any of this
now what Lady Stoneheart does next is
still up for debate or open to
interpretation when it comes to her
story one of the things I'm looking
forward to the most is obviously how
this Jaime and Brienne situation gets
taken care of let's assume Brienne gets
Jaime to follow her to lainey Stoneheart
how is Jaime gonna get out of this
situation without getting himself killed
unless he's able to offer them something
that is worth more than his own life
another thing I want to know is how will
Jaime react if Brienne never tells him
the truth about why she came to get him
Brienne is essentially leading him into
an ambush that could lead to his death
so I'm assuming he would see this as
being betrayed by Brienne unless she
gives him a heads up about what they're
walking into one very popular theory
states there will be another red wedding
but this time House Frey will be on the
receiving end of the blades basically
what could potentially happen is Brienne
delivers Jaime to Lady Stoneheart
and the Brotherhood without banners then
instead of killing Jaime he will help
them orchestrate their own massacre
after all Jaime's relationship what this
family has already started to fracture
and he doesn't really give two shits
about any other phrase just like in the
TV show Riverrun was taken from the
Tully's and it's now in possession of
the phrase Jaime could help Lady
Stoneheart and the Brotherhood without
banners get access inside the castle in
order to slaughter whoever they wanted
but even if Jaime doesn't help them get
inside Riverrun there are other options
the blackfish is still alive in the
books and he obviously knows his way
around that
[ __ ] I'm sure he could sneak in just
as easily as sneaking out there is also
talks of another possible wedding in the
mere future between Devin Lannister and
one of the phrase so depending on where
that takes place it might not be too
crazy to think someone could crash the
wedding it does look like George could
be setting things in place for this to
happen
he obviously brought Lady Stoneheart
back into the story for a good reason so
I don't think he wants beric Dondarrion
schist life to go to waste now speaking
of the kiss of life there is another
theory that involves Lady Stoneheart and
Jon Snow as of right now in the books
Jon Snow is still dead but many people
believe Lady Stoneheart could give Jon
the kiss of life there are some obvious
logistical issues for one John is all
the way up at Castle black and Lady
Stoneheart is down in the Riverlands
characters in the books aren't able to
travel as fast as they can in the show
so it would take quite some time for her
to get up to the wall not to mention she
is traveling with a band of outlaws and
I highly doubt they would want to march
right up the Kings Road but I will say
this even though many of us think Jon
Snow will be resurrected rather quickly
that doesn't mean he has to be there are
ice cells at Castle black so John's body
could be preserved in one of the cells
there is also evidence that Jon will go
inside of ghost for some period of time
and Melisandre chapter it said the
flames crackle softly and in their
crackling she heard the whispered name
Jon Snow his long face floated before
her now he was a man now a wolf now a
man again that sounds like it could be
foreshadowing Jon Snow's resurrection
process he will go from a man to a wolf
to a man again so who knows how long he
stays inside he ghost it could be enough
time for Lady Stoneheart to get there
and give Jon the kiss of life but then
again you also have to consider the fact
that Catelyn does not like Jon in fact
the last time they spoke she told Jon
that she wished it was him who fell from
the tower instead of bran that is
obviously some evil [ __ ] to say to
someone especially when he's only 15
years old and he's getting ready to go
spend the rest of his life in the Nights
Watch in the TV show we basically see
Arya Stark play the part of Lady
Stoneheart she was the one who showed
back up at the twins and dealt justice
to all the phrase
however I don't think it will play out
the same way in the books as of right
now Lady Stoneheart is still roughly in
the same area of the Riverlands she is
leading the Brotherhood without banners
as she hunts and kills anyone she thinks
assisted in the red wedding up to this
point
she has already executed a couple phrase
and she's only just begun my main
question for the video is where does her
story go from here I imagine she will
continue to deal out her own form of
justice but what's next can she ever
live a normal life again I don't think
that she can not in her current state in
my opinion she will die and I mean die
for good before the story comes to a
close some would say that Aria and Lady
Stoneheart stories will be linked until
the very end because Aria is on her own
mission of vengeance and she was also
the one who pulled lady Caitlin's body
out of the river another interesting
thing to keep in mind is this in the
books one of re as many nicknames is
Marcy and another nickname for Lady
Stoneheart is mother merciless some
people think this could mean that aria
will end up showing her mother mercy by
putting her out of her misery I'm not so
sure I can agree with this one either
the theory I believe the most is Lady
Stoneheart orchestrating her own
Massacre to get payback for her family
very similar to what Aria did in the
show but I don't think stone heart will
be using any poison I think it would be
a slaughter or a hang fest now it will
be very interesting when and if she ever
reunites with any of her children how
will they react to their mother's
appearance and dark personality this is
one of the main reasons why I don't
think Lady Stoneheart will live very
long I don't think she can ever be a
normal mother again not after everything
she has been through and who can really
blame her even if some of her children
survive and they get Winterfell back can
you really picture Lady Stoneheart
cooking dinner for her family or tucking
them in at night when her throat is
still cut wide open and her face is
mutilated I just don't see it
if someone doesn't kill her for good
what I think could happen is once she
gets her vengeance on her enemies and
she realizes what kids she does have
left are somewhat safe she might just
expire once she completes her mission
and gets that closure I could see her
just shutting down completely that's
pretty much her only purpose now anyway
so if she's able to do
that then I think George our Martin
would find a way to end her story
properly but that's just my opinion give
me your thoughts or questions on all of
this I know it was a long video but I
haven't talked about Lady Stoneheart in
a while so it was nice to dive into some
different ideas anyways I want to thank
everyone that has made it this far I
really appreciate you taking a time out
of your day to watch the video I also
want to thank all my supporters on
patreon because I appreciate that as
well I hope everyone has a great day I
will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]